let's have a look at this last question
so here we go this turns the tables on
us we need to produce the graph rather
just interpret the graph that they've
given us all the one set of axes you can
see I've got my axes already prepared
draw graphs to show two thousand dollars
invested app let me give you a whole
bunch of options okay now you can see
when you have a look at each of the
three options they ask you to go over 10
years so I've got just like i have seen
at the previous question I've got a time
axis down here and I'm going to label
that as years and that makes my vertical
axis the interest access song but it
just right interest over here and that's
going to be in dollars okay now because
they're all over ten years I've made the
largest value this value over here on
the right I've chosen to make that 10
you can see I've got a few spots already
marked out there so i'm going to write
in that's going to be 10 halfway would
be five and i have all of the none other
doctors here between here that'd be too
for their six and eight that's enough
for me if I need more detail as I go
through the question i will add it more
it okay now this is a bit interesting
because i actually think in order to
graph this well and make sure your graph
is accurate for part 1 2 and 3 I think
we'll actually be helpful to add to part
a first cuz I've worked out how far
across actually go I should go 10 years
but i don't know how high i should go
like should the highest value be a
hundred dollars thousand dollars billion
dollars I don't actually know yet until
I gets a part a so if I want to work out
what's happening after ten years I just
need to use my i equals PRN formula just
like I did before and I could work out
what's the maximum number now if I could
work at the maximum they don't know how
far the graph is supposed to go up and
they're all going to go on the same
graph so no big deal now I've got part
one part two and part three because each
one it's a say about of money saved at a
time but it's a different interest rate
okay so when you have a look if you go
with your calculator eight percent ten
years two thousand dollars this is P
aren't and pretty much perfectly a
taught us are going to go two thousand
times now think back a per set we wonder
as a decimal so that's actually zero
point
08 you could actually manually do that
eight percent 8 / hundred Chuck down to
your calculator convert it to a decimal
0.08 and then i'm going to multiply by
10 and that gives me 16 hundred dollars
that's the first one twelve percent if
you substitute now you're going to be
careful right because when you do 12 /
hundred it's going to give you 0.12 so
that gives me two thousand four hundred
and then when I have a look at the last
one ten point five percent because it's
got a point five it's got an extra level
of like that decimal point is more
accuracy the double you've got to punch
it as your decimal interest rate will be
zero point one zero five so you get
another decimal point there okay again
when you punch that in you get a thicker
so this is what's the whole amount of
money after 10 years so this is like the
end point for each of my three lines for
each of my three different investments
you can see there the biggest number is
two thousand four hundred dollars so I'm
going to make that the top because if
that's the highest value making that the
top everything should fit underneath it
okay so you can see over there on the
Left I'll zoom it a bit for you I've
actually already marked it I've got six
Marquis so six markings 2400 that's four
hundred dollars for each marking so I'm
going to label them now that's going to
be actually I've already got the dollar
sign there so this is just 400 this will
be 800 1200 1600 which will be useful to
us in a second two thousand and then
2400 which was the last level we were
expecting ok so now I've got that I've
actually ready for part one now because
I can say I'll do this in three
different colors so we'll make it what
should we choose you ok we'll go with
blue for this first one will go with
greed for the middle one and then we'll
make the last one pig okay so if I draw
by blue graph now it is going to end up
at this sixteen hundred dollars ok so I
could do that i can say at ten years
which is over here on the right-hand
side of the graph i want to measure up
to sixteen hundred dollars which looks
like it's about there ok now that's my
end point so all i need to do knowing
that you know
this is interest right so the interest
is going to start at nothing when you
have zero years and it's going to end up
at that spot I'm going to draw by libe
straight up so this is my first one and
I'm going to label this one eight
percent per atom okay then I have a look
at my middle one by green by twelve
percent it ends up at 2,400 so was the
highest value so about it again put a
point in there and just like before if
you bit in 40 years you don't have any
interest so I'm going to go all the way
to the origin and drop my straight later
they're just like I did before I will
label it and last one 2100 that's got to
be kinda in between so I've decided to
call this one pink 2100 should be just
above this a 2000 line right in fact it
should be a quarter of the way up
because each one is four hundred dollars
so i'm going to estimate it's about
their roughly okay again if you've got a
grid book you'll be able to do this much
more accurately that I can but again
I've got to measure it all the way to
the origin and that's what my graph
looks like okay last measurement last
labeling rather that's ten point five
percent per atom excellent so I've done
the first thing I've draw the graphs I
have also died part a I have worked out
how much investment over ten years now
will you have a look at this last bit
how much is sorry this next bit how much
is each investment earned after in
behalf use I've gotta use my graph right
now I'm measuring it for three different
things so if i go up i'll choose a color
like saying great I want to see where
eight and a half years is on by
horizontal axis that's clearly going to
be halfway between eight and nine so I'm
going to put my line halfway through
there and I'm going to draw it
vertically upwards like this I'm just
putting it added so it looks it stands
out a little bit that I can tell that
it's something different ok so now when
you have a look at this I can see all
right that vertical line for eight and a
half years it intersect with each of my
interest lines and that will show me if
I read across to the left
I'll be able to read how much I've
actually earned and I'm going to do the
best estimate I can't so if I pick let's
go with the will go in vertical order so
if I have a look at my eight percent per
atom line and if i draw across a load
like this okay you can see if i come
back to my answer there for part b four
part 1 it looks like that's well it's
below half way between 1200 and 1600
halfway between 1200 and 1600 is 1400 so
I've got to make an estimate so I've got
to write you know with a squiggly line
an estimate of thirteen hundred dollars
i think is a pretty good guess like i
said the big rubber autograph and if
I've got grid lights the more accurate I
could be but that's pretty good part
sooo okay maybe I'll do this one in
order this is the top line so if I go
down and draw a line across from the
intersection with eight and a half years
and I go all the way over like that you
can see i'm hearing the vertical axis
again and it's above 2000 doesn't look
very high above 2000 so baby my eggs
would be approximately 2015 i think
that's what's reasonable maybe that's
2075 lastly I've got to do this Pequod
here and I can see it's intersecting and
this one looks pretty much bang on
halfway between sixteen hundred and two
thousand so I'm going to go out on a
limb and I'll go to save part 3 it's
going to be 1800 ok now it's worth
mentioning that if I wanted to rather
than using the graphs I could just go
ahead and I could crunch the numbers and
I could use P RM just like i did in in
this case and I could work out for eight
and a half years for 8.5 is my value of
M I could work out what these exact
values are and see how close my graph
was okay all right let's have a look at
the last couple of questions part see
how much more than the others has the
best investment herbed after 10 years ok
so the best investment clearly is this
top one here
this twelve percent per atom and I've
actually already crutched all the
numbers so you can see what's the
difference between so this is this is
now Busta artery Part C for part one
it's at eight hundred dollars more all
right plus eight hundred dollars more
than that investment and for part three
the discrepancy the extra about is going
to be plus three hundred dollars so
that's how much more the best investment
has bird last question and this is again
going to reply to odds of lines how long
does each investment take to earn one
thousand dollars of interest okay so
just like before how i drew a vertical
line up and i said okay same time tell
me all the graphs at the different buddy
this time i'm going to go from the
horizontal axis and say i want the same
money that goes across and i want to
work out the different times so that I'm
not confusing myself I'm going to take a
few of my lines off here so I'm going to
get rid of all of these construction
lines and also this vertical load I want
to have a look at i want to say okay
well where is this one thousand dollars
on my graph and it should be because of
scale are chosen it should be halfway
between 800 and 1200 so i'm going to
draw again a dotted line cuts right
across it's going to look something like
this
so this is by one thousand dollars live
you can see that's where it lines up
with on the left and now I'm going to
draw vertically down from each of these
intersection points so you can see I
intersect once here once here and once
here at each of these will tell me well
how long horizontally how long is it
taking you to get this amount of money
okay again let's do this in order will
go from the slowest one the one that
takes the longest so that's this eight
percent per atom if I drop my load down
that looks to be roughly halfway between
six and seven maybe a little bit less so
I'm going to say as my answer for this
one apart d part one let's go with six
point four years it doesn't look quite
like 6.5 to be part 2 that's our blue
sorry I agree load the highest one so
the highest interest rate gets the 1000
all is the fastest because it's earning
that money quicker and quicker so I'm
going to draw a vertical line from here
and it looks to be not sure if this is
exact we can check the numbers later
that looks bang on with four years so
i'm going to write part 24 years and
lastly part 3 there's pig graph let's
choose the right color if i draw that
down it looks like it's just short of
five years okay so I'm going to label
that rather answer that as maybe four
point nine years so that is all of the
questions that we've been asked here and
you can see the processes that I went
through and how much this connects to
what we looked at last time with linear
relationships solve excitable detainees
equations finding these points of
intersection okay i do want to comment
that again all of the accuracy of our
artists and i really should say
approximate approximate approximate the
accuracy of those answers lives or dies
or the accuracy of your graph i could
already tell that there are bits here
which are a little bit off but i'm still
confident that they're close enough that
these are pretty good answers and
they'll
give me another feature that I could
maybe make a decision can I afford that
holiday or not can I should i take this
new job which will have less pay or all
pay all those kinds of things okay so
that will guide you to your simple
interest number one the calculations
number two the graphs have you got those
questions and then we'll after this
we'll have a look at what happens when
it's not simple interest well it's not a
flat rate but when they order the fact
that your interest rate should reflect
the fact that your bank accounts getting
bigger a bigger a bigger that's what
compound interest is all about